il était une fois dans un modeste
village deux petits alsaciens qui
grandissait auprès de parents laborieuse
effacés les néons l'avait appelé paul le
cas des fûts prénommé jean pierre le
temps passa paul et jean pierre était
devenu deux jeunes hommes qui ne
soupçonnait pas la célébrité qui les
attendait comment aurait il su que les
grands de ce monde leur tendre est un
jour une main familière mais l'effet
veiller les faits qui s'étaient penchés
sur leur berceau d'un bhl fait qui
s'activaient dans une cuisine car ce
sont les femmes n'est-il pas vrai qu'ils
ont jeté les bases de ce qui allait
devenir la maison et berlin et c'est sa
cité d'abord ma grand mère ensuite ma
tante et ma mère puis ce témoin
attendant c'est mon fils je me suis
marié en vendu avec un cuisinier
non non il n'était cultive pas que
payent les quais et intègre ça et vous
un violon une petite auberge au bord de
l'eau oui qui sera leur colère il
s'appelait là mais c'était pas comme
maintenant du tout à me fatiguer c'était
beaucoup plus simple c'était la
guinguette au bord de l'eau ont fait
c'est uniquement la friture et la
matelote comment ça se passe et n'en
veulent pas mais nous commencions à ben
vous venez en carriole mon grand-père
chercher les clients à la gare de
ribeauvillé en 8es les poneys où on lui
arrivait
il allait les chercher au train est déjà
un petit peu en voiture nous savons les
frères peugeot qui dès parmi nos
premiers clients avec les premières
voitures mais on avait le temps on
n'était pas pressé dit on faisait une
promenade
on attendait le papa le grand papa il y
des le poisson et on attendait que tout
soit prêt quand a commencé votre
carrière si je puis dire internationale
aux dix ans il ya dix ans quand nous
avons eu la grande chance d'obtenir la
troisième étoile michelin qui est une
consécration et aujourd'hui nous voyons
quatre générations d'eberle vous êtes
entré en cuisine je suppose que vous
aviez à peu près l'âge de ce bébé
vous pouvez ainsi dire oui vous avez
grandi dans une cuisine j'étais déjà en
cuisine à partir de 6 ans rêve et votre
formation ultérieurement
je vais fait mon apprentissage avec un
chef tout lequel j'avais énormément
d'estimé qu'il n'avait fait que des
grandes maisons bourgeoises qui était
avant la guerre à la coudée talent à
saint pétersbourg que orange est le roi
de grèce qui a ensuite été chef chez
rothschild à paris et celui à mon métier
si l'auberge de l'ill reste encore
aujourd'hui une affaire familiale
il a bien fallu cependant le succès
l'exigeant faire appel un personnel de
plus en plus nombreux tant en cuisine
qu'en salle et l'on compte en moyenne un
employé pour deux clients des clients
gastronomes certes mais raffinée et qui
viennent chercher ici la survivance de
tout un art de vie qualité irréprochable
du service excellence de la table charme
de l'environnement on comprend dès lors
que la réputation de ce trois étoiles le
seul dans l'est de la france se soit
étendu rapidement au delà des frontières
complémentaire à souhait les deux fêtes
se partagent les charges
paul est aux fourneaux jean-pierre à
l'accueil est ce que la gastronomie est
l'apanage des personnes d'un certain âge
où avez-vous de parmi vos clients
beaucoup de jeunes a de plus en plus de
jeunes et c'est pour ça c'est vraiment
réjouissant et je pars c'est pour quoi
que disent les mauvaises langues que la
cuisine là quand cuisine est morte
je n'y crois pas et je vois des jeunes
même souvent des étudiants que j'avais
hier et qui ont récolté un peu leurs
sous pour venir au bout de deux mois
pour faire un bon repas ici et c'était
merveilleux
on vit à l'auberge de l'ill pour bien
manger mais pour manger surtout quoi on
vient en fait pour manger des
spécialités de longue date la mousseline
de grenouilles le saumon souffler la
truffe sous la cendre la brioche de foie
gras et certains gibiers comme le
chevreuil
l'ailière est ce que les clients ont des
habitudes où il ya beaucoup d'habitués
qui savent déjà auparavant ce qu'ils
vont prendre et qui veulent évidemment
rester anciens plat aujourd'hui on ne
mange plus le matlock chez vous non
mange malheureusement c'est que les
poissons sont très dur à trouver
et pour avoir une très bonne matelas
anti-feu des très beaux poissons c'est
vraiment rare at roumanie donc vous
recevez par faire rassoit parfaire ou
par avion
tous les produits les crustacés juste
assez directement de roscoff la viande
directement de paris et les légumes
aussi de rungis de lyon
vous avez aussi beaucoup de produits
exotiques de fouet surtout en cette
saison
par exemple les haricots verts viennent
du kenya mais sont évidemment même
supérieur anwari converse dû me dire on
a des manques des papayes délit cheese
il n'est pas question pour vous de
travailler avec des produits congelés
ah non pas du tout non la congélation
détruit tout est soulevé la consistance
des chaires le nom on peut pas faire de
la bonne cuisine
si on n'a pas déplu produits de premier
choix
tu prends les plus belles vraiment
actuellement avez vous des difficultés
pour trouver ces produits
ac c'est je dirais même que d'ici dix
ans il sera beaucoup plus difficile de
trouver des bons produits que de faire
de la bonne cuisine
mais qui dit bon produit donc rareté
cherté du prix de revient à chasse est
sûr bien sûr
alors comment voyez vous l'évolution
justement de la grande cuisine de cette
tradition va elle va continuer mais elle
va devenir de plus en plus cher donc
réservé à certains privilégiés
oui seulement facebook avait décidé de
reprendre le flambeau
on vous a un peu forcé la main ah non
pas du tout on m'a jamais imposée non ce
n'est tout seul la mouche vous avez cru
tout petit j'ai grandi là dedans j'ai
toujours aimé que ce métier je vois pas
ce que pourrait faire d'autres méthodes
comme métier à ce pas et aujourd'hui
vous innovez parce que crée aussi une
cuisine à votre goût en créant créé on
s'arrange avait à deux avec mon père on
dispute un d'hésiter un véhicule toi
fais des essais et on met au point une
cuisine un peu différente un peu plus
légère
j'imagine que certains de vos clientes
se hasarde à venir vous trouver dans la
cuisine
oui très souvent notamment monsieur
loans le mini des affaires étrangères de
volante qui me disait toujours soigné
bien mon chauffeur c'est un grand gars
se nomme ici connaît mieux que moi
la tradition veut que chaque grande
maison possède son livre d'or et
l'auberge de l'ill n'a pas failli à cet
usage aussi qui tend notre table nous
sommes partis à la découverte des
célébrités qui nous avaient précédé le
gotha étaient largement représentés et
la reine juliana de hollande n'était pas
la seule tête couronnée à avoir ici
laissé sa signature sans parler des
princes et princesses innombrables des
personnalités politiques ou des vedettes
de l'actualité et du spectacle
mais
vous avez reçu chez vous des princes des
rois alors il est un peu normal que
ceux-ci vous êtes appelés dans leur pays
et qu'on vous est demandé de faire des
repas très officiel oui c'est un très
grand honneur pour la maison il ya deux
ans on a fait le dîner un dîner chez le
roi tuer
on a fait un déjeuner pour la reine de
volant et récemment on a fait un dîner
pour la cour impériale attirant ce sont
des opérations purement prestige pour
yahoo et ce uniquement prestige qu'est
ce que vous faites vous emporter tout
votre matériel et/ou emporte j'emploie
toujours tout même certaines machines
même certains outils puis faut tout
emporté parce que suivant le pays on
peut rien trouvé sur place
toutes ont mené par avion par cargo et
qu'est ce qu'on vous demande dans ces
pays là en général on nous demande de
refaire une petite carte réduite de
l'auberge de l'ill fait on essaie de se
débrouiller avec ce qu'on a là bas est
ce qu'on peut emporter sur cette carte
tous les grands crus sont présents les
bourgognes les bordeaux les beaujolais
et même des vins étrangers
mais les vins d'alsace y sont présents
bien sûr mais monsieur berlin est ce que
justement les vins d'alsace dans
d'autres régions sont appréciées ainsi
qu'il devrait naître ah non je crois que
le vin d'alsace encore beaucoup de
terrain à conquérir et je me rends
compte de l'ignorance ou banc des gens
comme on dit chez nous de l'intérieur
par exemple le muscat je ne recommande
pour l'apéritif
ils sont tout étonnés après de trouver
un banc aussi sec
bien sûr faune et le riesling ou connaît
le gewurtz mais après je crois ça
s'arrête donc mon joueur rôle
d'ambassadeur absolument
maintenant déjeuner
les cuisiniers surtout les grands aiment
parler métier se retrouver entre eux
c'est à paul bocuse en visite chez ses
amis et berlin que nous avons laissé le
soin d'apporter une conclusion on peut
voyager dans le monde entier
de quoi on parle on parle d'abord de la
cuisine et on nous dit toujours en
france et bien de la chance vous avez
les meilleurs produits et c'est vrai
nous avons les meilleurs produits et la
chose que la plus formidable et qu'il
faut surtout garder dans notre pays
c'est surtout ses cuisines régionales
je pense qu'en alsace il ya une cuisine
régionale peut-être puis à la choucroute
mais aussi beaucoup de choses dans la
provence ya la bouillabaisse à toulouse
et le cassoulet et ça faut pas oublier
c'est que vinho regional c'est ça qui a
fait la france
la fin